it's great to have back on the program
today dr isaac bogosh an infectious
diseases physician and scientist based
out of the university of toronto and
toronto general hospital great having
you back again
great to see you again
so where to even start um okay i mean
over the last uh over the last month or
so
we've seen a global decline of about 30
31 32 in daily case average uh the u.s
has seen a similar decline some
countries are a little bit ahead of that
some a little bit behind
what's the explanation here is it
vaccination getting to a critical point
is there still some seasonality we don't
understand is it just inaccurate
reporting and maybe cases aren't really
going down
yeah i think uh i think it's a lot of
the above in fact all of the above so
certainly in countries that have
significant vaccine access and vaccine
rollout that's definitely helping right
that's definitely keeping cases down or
driving cases down and we can't ignore
that but of course there's probably
other factors at play we know that
vaccine equity global vaccine equity is
a major issue there still are billions
of people around the world without
access to these vaccines mainly in
low-income countries and there are you
know in depending on where you are in
the world there are very significant
outbreaks uh and epidemics of this so
globally it's great to see those cases
go down um i think it's too soon to
start having you know mission
accomplished banners up or anything like
that we're still at a global level far
from the end but certainly in countries
with high vaccine uptake like the united
states like canada like many european
countries and the few countries in asia
yeah we are closer to the end we might
be in the second to third period rather
than in the first period like unfor some
other countries are so last summer of
2020 there was the correct belief that
the fall into winter in the northern
hemisphere was going to get pretty bad
at the time we were just starting to
roll out vaccines there was very limited
availability the peak ended up being in
the u.s it was basically january 20th
right around presidential inauguration
day
in other countries it was a little bit
earlier a little bit later and uh then
we saw the sort of big decline and then
we got the delta spike
this time around where vaccination
is available in many of these countries
and we're still not totally sure about
the seasonality match up that that sort
of mirrors the flues seasonality
what do we think about this fall and
winter in the northern hemisphere
right i think there's a couple of points
one is that when we talk about
seasonality it might mean different
things to different people and yes i'm
sure eventually this virus will have a
more seasonal component maybe it'll be
more present in certain times of years
like the colder months versus the warmer
months and and that's you know that's
very likely to happen with time but when
i'm talking about seasonality now i'm i
i'm oversimplifying it but it kind of
can be simplified in the sense that
whatever puts people indoors
uh is is a is a risk factor for greater
transmission hey it's cold outside and
it's september so kids are going back to
school many people are going back to
work in person and we're not hanging out
outdoors any as much anymore because
it's getting chilly we're spending
recreational time indoors and that in
and of itself at a population level can
certainly drive numbers up because
there's just innumerable opportunities
for this virus to be transmitted so when
we put that together and look at the
northern hemisphere yes it is getting
cooler people are going inside for more
and more reasons i think it's fair to
say that we will see peaks and valleys
but probably peaks throughout the cooler
months and the the fall and the winter
in the northern hemisphere and you know
it
sort of stating the obvious i think
areas that have more widespread vaccine
uptake will have more blunted peaks so
the amplitude of those peaks is really
under our control
in countries like canada the united
states that are fortunate enough to have
access to those vaccines you can
vaccinate yourself and and those around
you and your community you can create
safer indoor spaces as well with masking
with ventilation with crowd control uh
like there's a lot of steps we can take
to create safer indoor spaces at a
population level as well so that you
reap the benefits of of those uh
vaccination campaigns plus those
non-pharmaceutical interventions so
short story long yeah i mean we'll
probably have some peaks and valleys
throughout the fall and the winter but
how high those peaks go are under our
control we have the tools to keep this
under control
so
on speaking of tools there was a period
where it seemed as though every adult
was headed towards a third shot uh
originally the word booster was used but
when it was when the framing was no no
no it may be a three-shot regimen the
change of language was it's not an it's
not a booster it's just part of what
you're supposed to do
and then all of a sudden we started
seeing a change in tone to some degree
where at least in the us the
recommendation changed to only third
shots for 65 plus
uh immunocompromised pre-existing
conditions which if you include being
overweight and smoking is a lot of
people in the united states right i mean
but let's put that aside just for a
second here um what's your sense of
because there's the medical question as
to who would really benefit there's a
vaccine equity question as to should
people be getting third shots or is are
those better used as first shots in
other parts of the world
how should we be thinking about it
david i love how you separate those
questions because oftentimes that gets
confused and from a medical standpoint
like this is a very valid medical
question do people need a third dose of
the vaccine and if we want to delve into
that i think the answer is like anything
else it's a bit more complicated
i think there's good data to drive that
immunocompromised individuals however we
want to define it would benefit from a
third dose of a vaccine right they just
don't mount the same degree of an immune
response as other people and and as you
point out this could be viewed as you
know many people have had two doses of a
three dose regimen you need that third
dose for better protection we've known
this for a million years well before
covet 19 right there's a reason we give
uh immunocompromised individuals double
doses of for example the hepatitis b
vaccine like this is known
similar to that people who are on the
older end of the spectrum
will probably benefit from a third dose
of a vaccine in the united states it was
defined as 65 and up we could argue and
debate about the data but that's not
unreasonable including those who live in
congregate care settings like long-term
care facilities and again we've known
this long before cover 19 came around
there's a reason we give older cohorts
the higher dose influenza vaccine every
year because we know they need an extra
boost to mount an
immune response but
i gotta say and i you know when we're
you know i'm i'm sitting in canada now
when we were listening to the united
states discuss this if we were in
mid-august we heard very senior
political and public health leaders say
everyone's getting a booster shot at the
six-month mark oops pardon us sorry
everyone's getting a booster at the
five-month mark oops no no we meant six
months or eight months and then they
actually had to sit down and you had the
fda discuss it then you had the uh
vaccine experts discuss it like the
process
to get to this decision was very choppy
and i think did a lot of damage in terms
of public trust in the vaccine efforts
especially when we know many
unvaccinated people currently uh uh you
know we're for lack of a better word
we're trying to win them over we're
trying to show and demonstrate how safe
and effective and reasonable it is to
get these vaccines this didn't do a lot
of good in the in in getting to that
point unfortunately the other thing too
is
i don't know where it really landed in
the united states because it seems like
you know if you're a smoker if you're
obese if you may
work in a higher risk setting you can it
basically seems like it's open season
and anyone who wants to get a third dose
can get a third dose i don't think
that's that's really appropriate i'm not
to blab on and on but then let's factor
in
the equity issue you've got hundreds of
millions of people that are eligible for
a third dose when there's billions of
people who haven't received a first dose
and hundreds of or tens of millions of
americans that should be receiving a
first dose you want to get this under
control you get first and second doses
in as many people as possible rather
than third doses not to ignore that
there are some people who would really
benefit from a third dose so to sum it
all up
do we all need third doses now no we
don't do some of us need third doses now
yes some of us do
will we all need a third dose at some
point in the future yeah we might all
need a third dose at some point in the
future but we don't all need a third
dose now so in terms of protection level
which as you point out can be in terms
of larger populations
the protection level is lower for
certain folks and that's a factor in
thinking about these third doses
how should we be thinking now about how
protected one is
today
given the difference between the
dominant delta strain and what was the
original or live strain for which the
vaccines were calculated because
you hear
you still got a mask if you're
vaccinated because you can still spread
it and then you hear hey actually you
can but if you're vaccinated and
asymptomatic
it's not super likely but it's but it's
possible and it makes it makes it very
difficult to do like a risk assessment
of any individual so
when you read 99 98 97 of the cases and
and or at least hospitalizations are in
the unvaccinated
what does that tell us
yeah basically you know sometimes people
complain about shifting goal posts and
you're changing the rules and the answer
is yes of course they're shifting goal
posts of course you're changing the
rules and adapting policy you have to
because the virus has changed as well
and the delta variant is of course it's
the same virus but it functions in a
different manner it's way more
transmissible vers compared to the
original virus that emerged from wuhan
so yes you have to have these shifting
goal posts the problem is communicating
this and and telegraphing uncertainty
and and communicating that there will be
changes over time some we can expect
some we not we might not be able to
expect so that people don't feel like
they're getting the rug pulled from
underneath them so that's that's that's
one important point the second point
though is
yeah i mean delta is much more
transmissible but we do know that
if you're vaccinated
right off the bat delta or not well
especially even with delta you still
reduce the risk of getting copin 19 you
reduce the risk of getting
infected but you greatly reduce your
risk of getting really sick like landing
in hospital needing an icu or dying and
and there's just overwhelming data from
multiple countries demonstrating all
this the second point is you can still
get infected uh
with delta even if you're vaccinated
we've known that we've known that long
before delta even emerged in the
original clinical trials that were
published there were still vaccinated
people that got infected delta hadn't
even emerged yet so that's not new uh
but we do know now that if you are
vaccinated and infected
you're just much less likely to transmit
to other people of course you can still
transmit but the problem probability is
lower so you know for example if you
want to create a safe indoor space a
restaurant a bar a casino a daycare or
wherever the more vaccinated people you
have that indoor space you just reduce a
the likelihood that you're bringing
cover 19 into that space and b though if
it is brought in the likelihood that
it's transmitted to other people
of course that's one significant layer
of protection but we have to think of
this as layers of protection there's
other layers you can take masking
ventilation crowd control and when you
put all those layers together and you
add that to vaccines you want to get
really fancy add rapid testing at the
door the more layers you have the safer
the indoor space you have the more
layers you peel off you're just adding
incremental levels of risk and you've
got to find that sweet spot of what's
reasonable what's convenient and what's
necessary for that particular
environment
last thing i want to touch on
when do cases no longer matter in a very
specific sense i think it was with uh
h1n1
that at a certain point when it was
determined that it's no more deadly than
the flu strain of that year and correct
me if it's not h1n1 but it was a
different thing that i'm referring to um
at a certain point the testing stopped
because it didn't really matter whether
you had the flu or you had again i think
it was h1n1 because the protocol was no
different it was no more deadly the case
numbers may have been interesting but
they didn't really tell us anything
about the risk to an individual of
getting really sick from being out in
the world does it depend on the level of
vaccination does it depend on the maybe
reduced severity of
coronavirus as we go forward which may
happen or or it may not when do the case
numbers no longer matter
so i i think if you lined up 20 people
in the business you'd probably get
several different answers the way i
think about this though is
i like the case numbers but it has to be
put into the appropriate context right
there's a lot of data hospitalizations
icu's deaths cases vaccinated percent
positive blah blah blah blah blah
context is important so you have to put
the appropriate weight and and context
to each data point but when the case
numbers sort of start to
lower in the importance factor i think
it's in my mind it's really when we
start to see this virus not impact our
society as much anymore what do you mean
by that it's not resulting in an
overwhelming number of hospitalizations
or deaths or morbidity it's not
preventing people from doing what they
do and a lot of that's a value judgment
as well right there's a value judgment
here
it's it's kind of unfortunate and
disgusting to think about but at some
point we're going to have to
collectively decide
what is an acceptable
number of deaths per year right for
cobit 19. not nice to think about but we
have to figure that out like in canada
for example influenza kills 3 500 people
per year awful terrible get your flu
shot all of them are are tragic
but
as a country we've sort of come to terms
with that's about how many we see per
year we have to come to terms with how
many covet 19
deaths or cases or whatever is quote
unquote acceptable and and like again
these some will say zero
i i don't think that's practical uh of
course there's the letter rip crowd i
don't think that's safe or ethical as
well but eventually enough people have
immunity through vaccination or recovery
from infection that it just doesn't pose
a a a burden on the country or the
region as much as it used to you're not
going to overwhelm your your health care
system you can go to restaurants and
bars and live your life but it's the
virus isn't going away so it's going to
be a bit of a value judgment that's a
bit of a long-winded way of answering
that question but at some point as as
long as it when it's when it impacts the
country or the region less by not
overwhelming the health care system and
not causing
meaningful morbidity and mortality
that's probably when the case counts
don't matter yeah and it will still be
an a different call for different
individuals also based on their uh their
their level of risk and their
willingness to accept risk as well so it
there's no it's a it's a complex answer
because it's a complex question i guess
is the way we would say it uh we've been
speaking with dr isaac bogosh infectious
diseases physician and scientist based
at the university of toronto and toronto
general hospital always great catching
up with you
great to chat david